Opportunities and boundaries
were way larger and bigger.
And the world has so much to offer us.
But sometimes we are living in a box.
Nurit Reder, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm very good, thank you for having me.
Thank you so much for being here.
Where are you calling from right now?
I'm at my home office,
which used to be my daughter's room.
And yes, this is my new office,
which I think painted half pink.
I love it.
To make it more happy.
Amazing.
So, Nurit, you have such
a phenomenal track record
from so many CEO, CFO, VP positions
and so many different companies.
And just among them, WIX,
that everybody here would know about.
But give me a little bit of context
as to the journey
that you've gone through
and what really excites you
about joining new endeavors,
starting new endeavors.
You're involved in so many things
at the same time
that I just love to pick your brain
on several spots throughout your journey
and get some insight into things
that I can push forward
in my own journey later on.
So, Nurit, take me back.
Who are you?
Wow. Okay.
So, I'm from Israel.
I was born and raised in Israel.
Currently I live in Ramat Hasharon.
And I'm married with two kids,
two teenagers.
My career started at a very young age.
I was very lucky to join the
financial adviser to the chief of staff
as somebody who was only 21 years old,
in charge of billions
and billions of shekels.
It was a great start.
I'm working with the Knesset
and Ministry of Treasury.
Yeah, I'm not sure I knew how to,
how much how big it was.
When you are 21, you are very bold
and nothing scares you.
You have very little life experience.
So,
so, it's a good time to start.
When I was a finance officer,
and when I finished my service
in the army, I started my career.
And then I just,
I fulfilled many positions
in finance and operations.
I was CFO of several exciting
high tech companies.
I was in charge of operations and HR.
I can tell you, by the way,
that one of the smart things
that I can tell,
I made many mistakes.
But one good thing that I did
is took every opportunity
that came through.
I just jumped in.
And this is a major factor
in my career because
I had the opportunity
not to deal only with finance,
I could take operational responsibility,
and IT opportunity.
And so, I found myself
fulfilling not only CFO positions,
but also in charge of HR,
and sometimes IT.
And it really enriched my career.
And then, in 2013,
I had this amazing opportunity again.
Again, a huge door was opened to WIX.
And I must say again,
that I got to know WIX in 2008.
My amazing neighbor, Omer Shai,
told me about this amazing company
that is called WIX.
And that I don't know if many people
heard of it back then, I didn't.
2008. Wow.
Yes.
But then I went to a meeting there.
Nothing, you know,
came to something real.
But a few years later, I met again
with Avishai and Nir, the one and only.
And Nir and Avishai
and the two and only maybe.
And then they offered me to be this,
in this position of VP of operations,
which I
didn't really know what it meant.
I'm not sure they knew.
But I just felt it in my gut
that I would never say no to it.
And I jumped right in.
And these were,
you know, amazing five years in which
I did anything but the things
that I did before.
I was managing,
I was leading Customer Solutions group.
I was managing WIX's assets.
I had the opportunity to establish,
to establish the WIX Hub.
What is the WIX Hub?
The WIX Hub,
was the first time that we realized that,
you know, WIX is an online product,
right?
That online and offline must be,
or on-life and online must be connected.
There is no other way.
And our customers
were small, medium businesses
and we wanted to hear them.
So, the Hub connected between those
small and medium businesses owners
and our product.
In one way, one hand we could hear
what they need
and how they use our product.
And on the other hand,
we could help them
use the product better
with training, with seminars.
It was like, you know,
a place full of activity.
Started in Israel, continued in the US.
And, you know, along the way,
we also established the accelerator
for women entrepreneurs.
So, entrepreneurship
was the name of the game in WIX.
Yes, I myself, by the way,
during that time,
I established my nonprofit
called Dalit.
It's a personal story.
I wanted to raise awareness
for excessive blood clotting.
And I now have a community
of four thousand members.
And we won, like Knesset award.
But trust me,
it's a long way to go still.
But I can tell you
that WIX affected me doing that.
It's, again, that thing of the community
and this element of the community,
how you create a community,
how you deliver the message,
how do you
create a shared purpose.
So, this is, by the way,
a whole new area that we can,
I can talk about for hours.
Well, I want to also go back
for a second.
Because I'm seeing a pattern here
of jumping on to opportunities.
You're talking about
finding yourself at 21,
being the aide to the chief of staff
with regards to financials.
And then going on to
various CFO positions
and landing at the end
with the VP operations at WIX,
even though you have no idea
what VP operations does.
So, take to me little bit
about this mindset,
this growth mindset
of harnessing opportunities
and moving forward with them.
Well, okay.
So,
I can talk about a few things.
One,
I was always a dreamer.
I thought I was a dreamer.
I thought I aimed high.
And so, I didn't limit myself
only to being,
you know, at the age of 21,
my dream was to be a CFO of a company.
But then,
I kind of
reached it quite early,
And then, I
I didn't know where to aim next.
And it was quite confusing.
I very much believe in aiming high.
But when I came to WIX,
I understood I was not aiming at all.
I mean opportunities and boundaries
were way larger and bigger
and the world has so much to offer us.
But sometimes we are living in a box.
And I found out
that I cannot live in a box.
I mean, from time to time,
I returned to my box,
but it never lasts.
So, my box is that is finance.
But my gut was stronger
than the box thing.
And I can tell you that
every time a door opened,
whether it was being a CFO
of a product division at the age of 27,
where it was selling
for one hundred million dollars,
I jumped into it.
When my boss was sick
and somebody had to take some project
going to the US presenting IT project,
I also jumped into it.
I just didn't say no
to new opportunities.
When it scared me, I went for it.
And this was one good thing that I did.
But I think that you should always dream.
Like there is this book that I read,
the 10 times rule or something like that.
You need to dream really
like a big and scary dreams.
Because then you know,
you are doing the you know,
you are aiming to the right direction.
Wow.
That's very, very cool.
Yes, I think that I always put, I mean,
my career was always important for me.
I put it first.
Maybe it's not that popular
to say it when you are a mother,
or a politically correct.
But I can tell you that
I don't know any other way
to succeed in something
that you are aiming to accelerate.
If you want to succeed in something,
you can just tell yourself:
okay, it's a Saturday
and I'm forgetting about work.
It's merging into your life.
And I have very, I mean,
I have many examples
of why it's important
and why when you are focused,
you can succeed.
So, this is another thing
that I can tell you.
So, give me a little bit of insight
into the mistakes you've made.
You've mentioned that
you've made a lot of mistakes
along the way,
but you've grown from there
and you've learned from them.
So, what are some mistakes
that you single out along the way
that are clear to you
that they'd helped you
in your trajectory?
Whether it's through learning
or empathy or just understanding.
Yeah, well, that's a very good question,
and I've been thinking about it a lot.
So, one thing is that
I didn't aim high enough.
I can tell you that.
I have that intrapreneurship in me
for forever.
And only now I reached the point
where I'm doing my own thing,
my own business.
Something that I'm super,
super passionate about.
That I'm willing to
invest immensely at
and without any boundaries.
Well, I have that privilege
that my kids are older now,
so I have more time.
But I can tell you
that it wasn't the case
in the last 20 years of a career.
It was not always,
and when at WIX, for example,
I had opportunities
that I was amazed to be given.
I just gave everything.
And I didn't always,
I wasn't always
lucky to have those opportunities.
But you need to create
your own opportunities.
That was something
that I should have,
and you need to be
fearless.
And I was scared of many things.
Going to do my own thing was something
that was inconceivable to me.
Now, at a later age, I now I dare.
And so, this is one thing I can tell you.
There are so many.
Well, so, about this daring
and trying new things,
you approach these opportunities
and how do you navigate your environment?
So, there's expectation of you
from others.
There's expectation of you from yourself.
And then there's what your actual
skill sets are at that moment.
And you know that there is going to be
a big learning curve and a big, you know,
a big journey to get there.
So, it sounds like
a pretty lonely journey
to sometimes be in that phase
where they are expecting something
and now you have to own up to it
and now you have
to do this internal journey
to reach that milestone, right?
Yes.
Wow. That's an amazing question.
So, this goes back
to doing right or wrong
in  making decisions.
So, I think my conclusion is that,
the only way you can succeed
while you would like to grow
is by partnering with a colleague,
with a few colleagues,
creating a coalition, having a partner.
When I did that,
and I not always used that  way.
But when I did it, it just flew.
It just you know,
I had a partner I will not say his name,
he was from a different discipline,
which is also important
because I come from finance,
operation, HR, I can do that,
but I cannot do R&D, for example.
And if I want to do something big,
if I wanted to do something big,
something as strategic,
something with impact,
so that was the only way
because you can't do it otherwise.
Certainly in a larger organization,
but also in a startup.
If you want to  do
an important move,
something that will really affect
the life of the company
and make you feel
like you gave your best,
you need to partner.
You need to complete your skills
with other people skills.
You cannot do it alone.
You simply cannot.
So,
that's the way I do.
What has been most exciting for you
on your journey?
Like, are there certain points in time
when you really feel like
you are your true self
and you're really fulfilling
your destiny?
Wow.
I'm not sure I know
what my destiny is yet.
I'm always hoping that
what I do currently
is the most exciting things.
And I feel like it right now
because we are in the beginning
of this journey
of creating our own startup
in something that I very much believe in,
something that I learned a lot
being at WIX.
Everything that I mentioned
about community.
I will tell you this,
when I was it WIX,
I was part of an employee community,
which I was very proud to be part of.
And I asked myself,
why was I so proud?
And the elements are coming
from different kinds of worlds.
One is, for example,
that you had your responsibility
on your shoulders.
You could do many initiatives,
you can lead things
that never existed before
in that organization,
but it was on your shoulder.
Everything was measured.
You can picture that with me.
When you enter every floor at WIX,
you can see graphs and numbers.
And for me as a finance person,
it was a shock because
everything was transparent.
But
the amazing thing which I realized
a few months after was that
it was aligning everybody.
Everybody knew company goals.
Everybody wanted the company to succeed
and they knew what it meant
to be successful.
And on top of everything
that I'm talking about right now,
which is like the business world,
everything was wrapped in this
gift wrap of
taking care of employees,
having many, many, many events.
You are always being seen.
You are on the stage.
Somebody is taking care of you.
You know that your voice is heard.
So, social element is very strong
and very much connected
to the business world.
So, what I'm doing right now
in my startup is trying to take
this to the online world.
Because this is where we're going to be.
I mean, as I said in the beginning,
online and on-life
will always be connected.
We are not going to run away from that.
But how do you create
an online organizational culture
in a platform?
How do you create all of these
amazing elements in the platform online?
So, this is something
that I'm very excited about,
very passionate about.
I hope it's going to fulfill my destiny.
But then again,
I don't know what my destiny is.
It's a big thing.
I need to think about it.
What are the most critical parts for you
as you think about
who you want to work with
and the people you want to
align yourself with,
whether it's for this startup
or for any other project?
Well, again,
people make everything.
This is something
that I learned along the way.
Sometimes you are taking people
with not exactly the skills
that you need.
But you know they are smart,
you know they have a heart,
and they know how to work together.
And in bad times,
this is the test, right?
So, there is no, you know,
you never work on a project
and it's all roses
and smelling like hearts.
Little hearts, I don't know
You have those obstacles
that you need to deal with.
And you need that person
to be next to you.
And I had the luck to have
a few people like this
near me
in those situations, bad situations.
And we are still, you know,
10 years past, 15 years past.
But it's not always the case.
So, it's again,
it's an intuition or friends.
And now, I am
I have partnered to a real friend.
So, this is why I'm so happy.
Nurit, thank you so much
for being generous with your time.
This is really, really great.
I really appreciate it.
And at the very last question,
three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Three words. Okay.
That's a challenge.
So, I'm
a family woman.
I don't know if there is
such an expression,
I am a career woman.
And I am an entrepreneur.
I love it.
Nurit, thank you very much.
Toda raba.
This is really great.
And I look forward
to sharing this with the world.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.